[Música]
díganme algo les caen bien las personas
exitosas
les voy a cortar un poco de mí
yo era el tipo de niño que ganaban las
competencias deportivas escolares cada
año
a los 17 fundé mi primer emprendimiento
a los 19 hice mi primer negocio formal a
los 21 este negocio está evaluado en 10
millones de pesos
a la misma edad organiza un festival de
yoga y a los 23 escribió un libro
qué presumida estoy siendo verdad pero
no lo cuento para presumir lo cuento
para que sientan un poco de compasión
por mí
y no sólo por mí por todas las personas
enfocadas en logros
hay muchísimos casos reportados de
personas exitosas que sufrieron o sufren
de depresión
deportistas celebridades y empresarios
hay tantos ejemplos que empiezas a ver
una tendencia
y ésta sólo es la lista de las personas
que lo han hablado públicamente
déjenme explicarles por qué creo que
pasa
la motivación externa es hacer las cosas
por una motivación externa a ti
por ejemplo si tocas el piano para
impresionar a la gente por dinero o por
likes
imagina que comes con un pastel de
chocolate
eres feliz luego de hacerlo
seguramente tu respuesta sea que sigue
ahora qué tal si comes una segunda
rebanada sigues feliz
tal vez ya no sea lo mismo pero lo
sigues disfrutando
y si comes una tercera rebanada y estás
lleno e incluso se podría dar asco
si el pastel realmente te diera
felicidad el sentimiento no se iría tan
fácilmente sería algo permanente
el problema es que confundimos el placer
con felicidad
con el éxito pasa lo mismo
eres feliz cuando tienes el placer de
haber logrado las cosas pero luego se va
y buscas lo siguiente
por eso las personas enfocadas en logros
van de un éxito a otro tratando de ser
felices
la verdad es que las personas enfocadas
en logros son así porque tienen
presiones psicológicas internas muy
fuertes
a través del éxito quieren corregir un
aspecto emocional no sanado
quieren cubrir con éxito un vacío
interno
a través de los logros quieren
impresionar a padres severos que no les
mostraban mucho amor tienen ganarse el
cariño de la gente o quieren cubrir el
dolor de un ser amado que ya no está
díganme puede ser infeliz aún cuando lo
tienes todo
claro a pesar del éxito externo puede no
haber plenitud hay muchísimos ejemplos
de personas aparentemente exitosas que
no eran felices e incluso se suicidaron
la vida de robin williams es un gran
ejemplo de motivación externa
robin williams fue de los actores más
famosos y exitosos de todo el mundo
tenía éxito en todo lo que se proponía
empezó haciendo comedias teatrales
ganó un premio emmy por la serie work in
day
los números tres veces a los óscar es
por sus actuaciones de comedia
después y su actuación es de personajes
muy complejos y ganó el oscar a mejor
actor por la película mente indomable
también ganó cinco globos de oro por sus
actuaciones y paralelamente a su trabajo
de actor hizo álbumes hablados de
comedia con los cuales ganó cuatro
premios grammy
en cualquier aspecto en el que decidí a
trabajar era muy exitoso iba de un logro
a otro pero nunca nada era suficiente
fue votado en varias ocasiones como el
hombre más cómico llegó a ser de los
actores mejor pagados y era de las
personas más queridas en todo el mundo
se podría decir que lo tenía todo
entonces que lo llevó a suicidarse
hizo a todo el mundo feliz excepto a sí
mismo
todos tenemos o hemos tenido una
condición imaginaria cuando pase esto
seré feliz cuando logre esto seré feliz
tenemos que aprender a apreciar nuestra
vida a disfrutar del camino y hacer las
cosas por un propósito interno
la motivación interna es tocar el piano
porque te da alegría no lo haces para
obtener nada a cambio lo haces porque la
experiencia por sí sola vale la pena
la vida de jane goodall es el ejemplo
perfecto de motivación interna jane
goodall es la primatóloga más famosa de
nuestra época es conocida por pasar 55
años estudiando chimpancés
transformó nuestra visión sobre el mundo
animal y su conservación pero cómo es
que llego a ser la persona que es ahora
desde muy pequeña tenía curiosidad por
los animales y la naturaleza en su
autobiografía cuenta como una de sus
tareas de pequeña era recolectar los
huevos de la granja familiar tenía
cuatro años y empezó a cuestionarse de
dónde salían los huevos
nadie le explicó de manera correcta así
que decidió averiguarlo por sí misma se
escabulló en un gallinero y esperó
pacientemente durante horas simplemente
observando mientras tanto su familia ya
estaba en estado de pánico e incluso
había llamado a la policía para ellos
james estaba desaparecida desde hace más
de cuatro horas
en lo que la buscaban jane por fin vio
de donde salía un huevo emocionada
corrió de manera impaciente a su casa
para contar su historia su mamá vio el
brillo de emoción en sus ojos a pesar de
la preocupación no la regañó notó su
pasión y se sentó a escuchar la historia
de como una gallina pone un huevo
qué clase de padre hace eso
un padre promedio lo hubiera regañado y
en ese momento la chispa de curiosidad
de james se hubiera perdido la
curiosidad de un niño es muy frágil en
cualquier momento se puede romper si ese
día la mamá de james lo hubiera gritado
jane goodall como la conocemos no
hubiera existido
recapitulemos las enseñanzas de las
historias como cambiamos motivación
externa por motivación interna
el primer paso es que tenemos que seguir
nuestras curiosidades y nuestras
pasiones
papas dejen que sus hijos se dediquen a
lo que quieren
escuelas dejen que los alumnos elijan
sus materias
una de las bases que llevo a steve jobs
al éxito laboral fue que después de
salirse de la universidad estuvo varios
meses como oyente dejó de asistir por
obligación y se metió a todas las clases
que realmente le interesaban como la
clase de caligrafía sin esa clase sus
productos no hubieran tenido tan buen
diseño
cuando tienes motivación externa vas del
logro en logro queriendo ser feliz y no
te importa si pasas por encima de la
naturaleza u otras personas para lograr
tu objetivo
por eso vivimos como vivimos
hacer lo que amas y dirigirlo a una
causa mayor es lo que realmente te hace
pleno
la última pregunta es cómo encontramos
nuestra motivación interna
el primer paso es hacer una lista de
todo lo que nos causa curiosidad
el segundo paso es encontrar la
intersección buscas el punto en común de
tres o más curiosidades es ahí donde se
encuentra nuestra pasión y donde hay más
energía
el tercer paso es hacer una lista de
retos mundiales para la humanidad
el último paso es enfocar tu pasión en
contribuir a uno de esos retos mundiales
y así tienes tu propósito de vida
sigamos nuestro propósito a pesar de
todo a pesar de las expectativas de los
demás a pesar de haber tomado otro
camino y a pesar de creer que ya es muy
tarde
la vida no es sobre éxito reconocimiento
o fama
esos son placeres efímeros lo que
realmente permanece es disfrutar aquello
que nos hace plenos gracias
[Aplausos]